thank you so much I am incredibly
honored to be here my name is Paul
Frazee and today I'm going to be talking
about formalizing user rights on the web
now before I get started let me give
some context about Who I am I'm located
in Austin Texas I'm a JavaScript
developer I've been working with node.js
for about five years I've been making
websites and web applications for just
about all my life I personally have an
enormous amount of passion for
distributed systems and peer-to-peer
technology I think they're technically
fascinating but I also think that
there's an incredible potential in these
kinds of technologies that have not yet
been leveraged in the web and so that's
what I pursue a lot in my daily life I
was one of the people who helped start
the secure scuttlebutt project which is
a peer-to-peer social network and
scuttlebutt is extremely active today
but now I spend my days working on the
Beeker browser and beaker is an
experimental peer-to-peer web browser we
work on it because we want to see if
it's possible to let users publish
websites without having to use servers
at all we want to see if you could just
have a button perhaps in the browser you
can click that and then you can publish
the site from your laptop or from a
mobile device and then you don't have to
worry about operations and things are
much easier for you now if you're
curious to hear a little bit more about
how that works like they said earlier
you should listen to Tara Vance's talk
later tonight she's giving a talk called
imagine this a web without servers what
I'm gonna be talking about is a little
bit about what animates us to work on
this project why we care so much about
this idea and why we think it can have
such a positive effect on the web now we
are huge advocates for the open web I
think it's incredible that we have the
shared platform that's not encumbered by
any patents or licenses and that isn't
owned by any one corporation but lately
I think the web has been struggling with
systemic problems issues with things
like bullying and harassment online
misinformation campaigns that affect our
elections infringement of personal
privacy
and honestly the list goes on now I
think in a way all of these systemic
problems stem or have some kind of
relationship to one basic question and
that question is who's in charge now I
don't mean this in a sort of a petty
sense like who happens to be the market
leader from one moment to another but
actually in a very profound sense about
who has the authority to govern our
communities and our applications and our
online lives and more importantly than
that perhaps what gives them that right
to be the people that govern our
experiences on top of that I think we
all sorts had to understand what kind of
rights we have as users what rights do
we have to control the software we use
what rights do we have to control the
algorithms that affect our perception of
the world what rights do we have to
control the moderation policies that
affect these issues that affect us every
day and so you can talk about political
rights in fact there's been some amazing
work recently with the gdpr
but there's actually something else
there's a kind of right that emerges I
believe specifically from the technical
design of the web and the architectures
of networks in general and this
technical right is derived from what
everybody is able to do and so that's
the right that we're going to be talking
about here today now I think it's
important that we go through some of the
stuff that is the problem right now
which means we're gonna have to go
through some slightly offensive content
I tried to censor it a little bit so it
shouldn't be too bad but just so you
know it's kind of annoying let's start
with talking about harassment well
mostly talk about Twitter but Twitter of
course is not the only community that
has this problem
here's Susan Fowler talking about
anti-semitism filling her notifications
just recently Jessica Valenti had a
death threat in her notifications she
had to struggle a little bit to get
Twitter's moderation teams to take it
seriously you don't have to go far to
find this kind of stuff and I don't
think this is news to anybody the
internet is full of trolls right in fact
the running joke at this point is that
Twitter is a cesspool well
you could say that this is just how it
goes we should develop a thick skin and
perhaps this kind of behavior is just
the cost of free speech and perhaps
that's the case except that I'm
beginning to believe that this kind of
behavior is affecting our culture and
our political systems I don't think I'm
the only one to think that at the end of
last year Reed Hoffman weighed in on
this issue how he would solve the
problems of hate speech and bigotry and
things like that abuse on our social
media platforms so Reed Hoffman is the
co-founder of LinkedIn people will want
to hear what he has to say
so in this interview he basically gave
his prescription and it was this these
are private businesses all these social
media platforms they're private
businesses and they can set policies
about what kind of behavior they expect
from their from their users from their
participants on the platform the
metaphor that he used is this kind of
like a hotel or a restaurant you could
set a policy no shirt no shoes no
service right the same thing here
project a more opinionated view about
what kind of speech is permissible on
your platform that's what he's putting
out now to some degree I actually think
he has a fair point
but what he's suggesting really
highlights what I think is kind of a
constant problem with how the web works
it kind of highlights how we're all
stuck between a rock and a hard place on
this matter because on the one hand I'm
not the sort of person who is animated
by a concerns about censorship
that's not my day to day my day to day
concern is much more about bullying or
death threats to somebody I love or
misinformation campaigns that might
affect the elections in my country that
bothers me a lot more but at the same
time I think you cannot ignore the fact
that we just had a very serious
conversation about the possibility that
Mark Zuckerberg could run for president
and this guy runs one of the most
powerful information sharing platforms
in the world over two billion users use
Facebook to get their daily news so the
idea that we at this juncture would
start to ask corporations to more
proactively police our speech is
actually I think a slightly bad idea
and so it seems like we're stuck between
these two options on the one hand you
have troll topia where everything is
permissible and on the other hand you
have a sort of corporate hegemony where
speech is being policed by big
businesses and it seems like there ought
to be something in between this
something which is perhaps driven by
users and yet it's not there
as it happens Mark Zuckerberg is not
particularly interested in reading off
man's suggestion he's extremely adamant
that Facebook is not a media company
they're just a tools company if they
were a media company they would control
what kind of media is put on Facebook
and that's his point that's not their
job and he says this because to be
honest he wants Facebook to be popular
as soon as they start getting into these
hard decisions about what sort of
behavior is permissible they very easily
get into partisan fights and they start
losing users because they're seen as
biased and this sort of dovetails nicely
into a conversation about misinformation
so we're still in our systemic problems
portion of the talk here let's talk a
little bit about what happened to 2016
American election this is a Washington
Post article and we're going to go
through some of the ads that will run
illegally by a Russian propaganda arm
using Facebook's ad targeting platform
this first one if you were opposed to
Muslim immigration you get this law from
this Russian propaganda organization
saying Sharia law should not be
debatable if you were a Christian
conservative you got Jesus or I'm
wrestling the devil if the devil one
then Clinton won the election if you're
supportive of strong borders you got
this no invaders allowed if you're a
southern conservative you got a fake tea
party endorsement for Trump they
actually spanned the political spectrum
though if you're an LGBT supporter you
got this ad against the Westboro Baptist
Church which is a hate group if you're a
Hillary Clinton supporter you got this
ad talking about Ethel Clinton is
supportive of Muslim citizens the
strategy that we're pursuing is getting
you to click like because then they
could push more propaganda to you and
then the meadow strategy was to
strengthen Trump's pace and divide
Clinton's
there's a lot of examples of what
happened and what went wrong in the 2016
election with misinformation I think if
you want more you could look at what
happened and read it and of course
Twitter has its own problems but this
next example that I decided to fit in
with the time I have I think was
important to illustrate because it
really cuts to the heart of how this
sort of stuff happens and that's this
one this is an article published by
ProPublica Lee at the end of last year
there is a advertising demographic on
Facebook it was jus haters you could
target jus haters with your ads it was
apparently 2274 people put this as their
field of study now I don't know if they
thought they were being funny or if they
were serious it doesn't really matter
but somehow Facebook's algorithms picked
up on this and started to make it a
group that you could advertise to I just
want to point out that UI element
underneath there yeah I think so okay
why is this happening is Facebook
intentionally setting out to collude
with the Russians to mess with our
elections in America is there some
Facebook employee that is adding that
jew-hater entry into the database I
don't think so
I don't think that's what happened I
don't know but I doubt it what I think
is happening here is the same thing that
happens with every Silicon Valley
company that is trying to achieve
enormous amounts of scale they're just
using algorithms and they're accepting
user data without considering just how
problematic that user data could be this
is a screenshot of YouTube David hog is
one of the parklands shooting survivors
so he's a high school kid survived a
school shooting which keeps happening in
America he decided to become extremely
vocal about his opposition or actually
his support rather excuse me his support
for gun control people who didn't like
his politics decided to spread a
conspiracy theory that he's actually a
paid political actor what you call a
crisis actor and so I guess enough
people search for that on YouTube
because gradually that started to show
up is the only thing whenever you type
in his name all these suggestions that
you should look into him being a crisis
actor so it's a combination of these
algorithms and then what I could only
describe
I suppose the political weaponization
that's occurring on the web and that is
going to continue to occur because these
platforms have the power to push an
agenda and every time you have one of
these algorithms that blindly trust user
input
that's another vector it's another
opportunity to push propaganda okay
these are problems the problems in how
we govern our communities online and
when you see problems like this I think
you naturally have to ask who's in
charge whose job is it to solve these
kinds of problems and I think this is
where we see technology and civics
collide in an incredibly specific way
because we're talking about the system
of authority in the system of governance
whose job is it to maintain these
communities online if you look at reddit
it's ostensibly designed to be a
democracy in fact it's probably one of
the most democratic websites online that
the users submit stories and then they
vote on what shows up on the front page
it's great but if you actually look at
the civic structure of Reddit it's not
actually a democracy it's actually more
like a monarchy because you sure you
have the users voting on stories
submitting comments and voting on those
as well then above that you have
moderator users and they have the power
to remove content to remove users things
like that but then on the top you have
the reddit staff and they're basically
the kings of this of this community they
have total control they can change the
code they can change the data they can
do anything and in fact they sort of
highlighted this about a year ago when
Steve Huffman decided to he's the CEO of
Reddit he decided to jump into the
Donald and manually edit some of the
comments of users in the Donald he
figured it'd be funny you know if they
trolled the trolls right and perhaps if
you didn't really know how websites work
you might be shocked to realize that
somebody on the right staff could just
change people's comments but I think
probably most of us here are
technologists and word intuitively aware
well of course they can do that they run
the server right
so that's dovetails into this next
question what is it about the web that
makes it like this why did the reddit
staff act as the king and why do they
have total Authority I think it flows
directly from this thick server design
the architecture of applications on the
web fix server is actually a technical
term it means that we put all the
business logic into the server and
actually as a result all of the
authority so if you diagram it it looks
a little bit like this
you got the thick server at the put up
at the top and you have the database in
there you have all the code and you have
all the authority placed in the server
and then you have the web browsers the
clients and you actually call them a
thin client thick server thin client and
the thin client is just a view of this
data just a rendering of what's
occurring on the server and anytime you
want to do something as one of the
clients you actually have to ask the
server to do it for you so all the
authority lives in the server and if you
have any authority as a user you're
actually just borrowing it from the
server in a way well what is it about
the web that makes it like that why are
the servers King there's nothing in the
nature of computers that make it this
way if you look at computers in a state
of nature hanging out next to each other
look at a server you look at a normal
desktop computer or a laptop sure the
server's more powerful but that doesn't
necessarily mean that the server ought
to be King sir doesn't have to be in
charge but that's how it is so why is
that if it's not in the hardware the
answer has to do with this it has to do
with the specifications and the
standards that define the web HTTP HTML
all the web AP is they encode this set
of behaviors this is a very clear
example of how technology doesn't just
interact with civics but it actually
drives civics it defines what the civics
structure of a community is going to be
in a way you could say that these
specifications are like a shared
contract
between us or perhaps even kind of like
a Constitution because they define how
our online society of computers are
going to work with each other there's
nothing in the hardware that does this
it's in the specifications it's in this
shared agreement it's these rules that
bind us together and define how our
computers will relate to each other and
it really is kind of like a contract or
Constitution because it's just an
agreement between the devices to follow
these rules it isn't a constitution like
the kind but these people made but it is
the kind made by people like this the
hackers that set the web in motion and
then produce documents that look like
this but it did produce specs like this
and there is a parallel there because
all of our computers everybody here we
use the image tag that's how that
happens so when we ask what gives the
server the right to be king over our
application well the answer is that it's
in the architecture it's how the web is
designed now it's not just the authority
model that's encoded in these
architectures it's also the individual
capabilities of everybody in the network
what can my computer do on the web
those questions are answered in the
specifications and this gets us back to
that ad you ever write what rights does
my machine have what rights to the
server have and so I'm going to try to
get us a term here an architectural
right this is a right that is given to
my device and it is encoded in the
architecture of the web or really of any
network let's go through some examples
to kind of make it intuitive here we
have a local area network we're gonna go
with a pretty natural design for a local
area network everybody can connect to
everybody else so we have Alice Bob and
Karla their machines can talk freely to
each other and so you might say that
there's an architectural right in this
design there's a right for everybody to
connect to everybody else you don't have
to make the land this way you might
decide that alice is actually much more
important and you can't maybe trust Bob
and Karla in your architecture so you
can do it like this where only Alice is
allowed to create new connections
and Bob and Karla they just have to
listen you definitely could do it this
way but if you did you'd basically have
a two-tiered architecture two kinds of
citizen Alice who has the right to
connect and Bob and Karla who do not
they can only listen let's look at
another example of the Internet
Internet's kind of like our Lynn because
the Internet has the same basic
principle everybody should be able to
connect to everybody else should be able
to connect to everybody else so you
could say that there is a right to
connect globally encoded in the design
of the internet in the architecture of
the internet again you didn't have to do
it this way you could do it like China
has done it oh well excuse me I just
want to point out sometimes the internet
doesn't work quite so well because
there's not enough IP addresses and
their firewalls that's what that slides
about now like I was saying you don't
have to do it this way you could do it
like China does it right you could set
up a global government firewall or you
could set up something like a municipal
server somewhere that you have to talk
to and ask permission to make a
connection that is how you could do the
internet we chose not to we chose to
make it so that everybody can connect
everybody else and I think that means
something really important it means that
there is a value set encoded in that
standard and all the standards that's
defined the web a right to connect
globally it is not a neutral decision
okay so we have an idea about how
architectural rights work let's take a
look at the web you might say there's
two kinds of citizen on the web like we
were talking about before you have the
client and you have the server and the
client is your browser or your user
agent so let's step through some of the
rights that each of these kinds of
citizens on the web have well the client
of course has the right to browse and go
from one website to another and visit
content of course I can do that clients
have the right to filter as well you can
run an ad Walker
you might also call this a right to
mutate because you could run extensions
and change things once you receive them
this is up to some interpretation but
I'd say those are the two that's really
what a client is allowed to do on the
web so let's look at a server
servers have the right to an identity on
address a comm right and only servers
have that on the web browsers don't have
addresses they don't have identities if
you want to have an identity on the web
you either need to be a server or you
need to ask a server to make an identity
for you
because they're the only ones with the
right to do that so that's why I'm
twitter.com slash P Frazee alright let's
look at the next write a right to
publish this is what a server is
designed to do on the web so what they
do whenever they're hosting content
they're publishing that content again
that's a write that only the server has
the client can't do that
if I want to publish something I either
need to be a server or I need to ask a
server to do something and that's why I
do all my tweets on Twitter comm because
they control the publishing servers have
a right to moderate as well they can
choose what they publish sort of falls
naturally out from having the sort of
dominant right to publishing and then
servers can also choose what code they
deploy they get to choose the data model
they get to choose how the application
behaves where the data goes now when you
look at this two-tiered citizenship on
the web it's kind of totally
unsurprising that there's an
asymmetrical power dynamic involved here
because not only do the servers have
more rights they're way better rights
that's the power to control how the web
applications work the clients they're
passive the best thing they can do is
make a choice about where they go so
when you're talking about these problems
of governance online how do we solve
these tough questions about moderation
policies and the truth of information
and you're asking well how can we make
governance better I think you have to
start by asking how could we give new
rights to clients so that the civic
structure is no longer being constrained
by the design of the web and the
architecture can have a more perhaps
even democratic design and how its
governed could we make it so that the
client actually has the right to publish
instead of always depending on a server
to do it for them we make it even so the
client has the right to having an
identity so that my personal identity is
no longer tied to whatever happens to
Twitter
when we even give clients the right to
deploy the code so they could decide how
their applications should work now I
mentioned at the beginning of this talk
that I work on peer-to-peer networks in
this context peer-to-peer networks
really fascinate me
because unlike client-server networks
they connect nodes in a way such that
they all have the same capabilities the
rights are completely evenly distributed
and appear to pure network in fact
that's sort of implicit in the name
we're all just peers I think that has an
equalizing force across the network it'd
be easy in a way to make this talk
largely about free software because in a
lot of ways that's deeply connected this
ability to control our right to modify
how the experience works but I actually
think it's a little bit bigger than that
I think it's about our ability to decide
how code works as a community that makes
it a question of civics not just free
software every time we ask Twitter or
Facebook to make a change to their
moderation policies to their feet
algorithms even to their interfaces it's
actually kind of a big deal requires
those companies to take a risk to
potentially lose users or change
something that's fundamental to their
success in the past and as a result they
may not be willing to make those kinds
of risks well when users have the option
to develop the software completely on
their own to pursue their own needs and
problems and ideas they don't have to be
afraid that it might hurt their bottom
line they don't have to think in terms
of maximizing their engagement numbers
they can just think about solving their
own problems as technologists I think
it's our job not to solve problems for
people but to give them the tools to
solve those problems so that they can
decide what is best for them especially
in these contexts of these global
societies like the web is I think
perhaps it's easy to think of the web as
being somewhat fixed and in disabled
places if we've already experienced the
full history of the web but the web has
only been around for about 30 years so
what are the next 30 years gonna be like
are we going to continue to use Facebook
and Twitter is it gonna be the same
governance model are we still going to
have servers as king or are we as users
going to be defining much more of our
experience in the future really think
about it 30 years from now is it going
to be like this I believe in civic
engagement and I believe it in all kinds
legal rights and regulations are very
powerful and I'm extremely excited about
what the gdpr will do for our industry
but the legal system is not our only
option and as people who shape
technology and shape the web we have
powerful tools at our disposal
technology is not neutral it encodes a
set of values and as a political system
it encodes a set of Rights and so it'll
be up to us to decide what our unlike
online civic structures will be like and
I hope you take this time to consider
which structures of power and which
rights you're enabling and the
architectures that you build if they go
very much
[Applause]